[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we want
today we've got
the day
dude
last jk news you guys remember when we
had other white steve here mannequin
steve he's chilling over there he's
chilling over there
did you guys say anything about what
happened no oh really because well at
first we thought you had corona so all
of us were continuing jk news with the
thought of maybe we got some corona
right oh we sent our blood already but
he went to the urgent care yeah just all
of a sudden so like you know i was
hosting that day and then all of a
sudden like at lunch i just started to
my heart was like going crazy like just
beep beep beep beep beep and i checked
my little my little apple monitor buddy
and it's a heart monitor yeah i have a
heart monitor on this and then it said i
was at like 138 beats oh [ __ ] that was
rave music and i was just just sitting
down i know we were just sitting down
like maybe walking back and forth
whatever but made no sense so then i was
like all like i was lightheaded and i
was like what the [ __ ]
and then um did you feel i got
adrenaline in here or what did it feel
dizzy dizzy but not like completely out
of it i was very mentally aware but but
i was also like this is weird i'm not
used to this
so then i was like yo anthony can you
take over for me because i already had
all the articles all set all laid out
but then he doesn't know what the [ __ ]
they are um and then he's like yeah sure
and then i
bailed out of here
when i got that bathroom too there was
like lysol disinfectant everywhere and
then they're like joe we gotta talk to
you i'm like what happened steve just
bailed out man he's going to the urgent
care right now and we're just
disinfecting everything and i'm like
does he got corona
i know i felt so bad too leaving on you
guys um but yeah i i um
you know you guys know me i like the
deals
i didn't my wife is like just go to
urgent care i called nikki immediately
she's like just go to urgent care and
i'm like
how far is kaiser i'm like i'll just
[ __ ] i'll drive myself guys
why because if you have a dirty
heartbeat 130 yeah because i might think
that's where i'm insured at so i'm like
i'll get the [ __ ] deal there's one
involved
yeah i know i know oh see i didn't know
that's not my kaiser so i was like i'll
just drive all the way because you could
go to all the kites it's like 45 minutes
away oh because you can go all the time
it took so long but i [ __ ] did it
bro
all of us are sitting here waiting to
figure out i'm still going to this is
about to pass out on the [ __ ]
driver's seat and he's driving he was
vin diesel well i was able to
i had a rule i was like i will pull over
if
if i
can't get my heart rate under control
right now so i was just breathing in the
car and like just like you know trying
to like almost meditate over the [ __ ]
yeah and i was able to get my heart rate
to like less than it's not like i'm in a
james bond movie guys it's hard to stop
or anything yeah but i was like you know
i was able to just calm down a little
bit because i think i was just freaking
the [ __ ] out picture nipples was it also
just like anxiety too
maybe that's what it was right so then i
i get there i have to wait like i don't
know two hours whatever and then they
yeah the other way two hours it was a
pain in the ass but then they saw me
well good night
and then and then they saw me and they
checked all my they took all my [ __ ]
they did all my blood work everything
they took me for corona none of that it
was just they think maybe an anxiety
attack caffeine inducing that because i
induced as he was telling me all these
things i was like i i went through the
same exact thing when i down the cafe
set up
the baguette so [ __ ] good i i think i
went and pounded the whole thing in like
20 20 minutes or whatever less
and then
in the middle of jk news i remember
going through the same thing heart was
beating like crazy i felt like i was
turning purple and then like people are
laughing so i'm just like
well i think i'm gonna have a heart
attack in the middle of it
god and i remember that day too
and i was like oh dude this is crazy i
might pass out right now
and then i just waited
and it went away so i was like damn
those sound really similar to that and
it's probably not corona but then you
have this cough thing so that's what it
was scary too but i know that sugar
sugar [ __ ] with me and makes me makes
me have like phlegm or whatever
so yeah unfortunately that that happened
to couple with it so yeah it definitely
felt i definitely thought maybe i had
corona i didn't know yeah and then tim
shows up
and then he so he was like oh you guys
might have another corona scare again
with jk
like get the [ __ ] out of that she's like
you get the [ __ ] out of there so don't
go anywhere near the park
tim [ __ ] bounced out now he's gonna
get a delta from us and [ __ ] like damn
he got all the variants from us dude i
was like i gotta go to hawaii i gotta do
a test for hawaii soon yeah and i'm like
[ __ ]
so they did ekg and all that stuff check
me out i'm good they just told me to
what did they say it was they said what
joe said maybe it was an anxiety attack
we're not sure just try to avoid
jose he's like did you have a cafe to
death
basically i didn't get much sleep the
night before because i was helping some
friends like mediate a
luna yeah
and i yeah we're in the crypto's
crushing it um but but so then that
coupled with like
caffeine stay awake just was a bad
mixture and so yeah it just it just now
i really respect the hospital protocol
because i had a buddy
he's like a like a super smart elite
performance coach we shot a video
and uh he left already and i finished
the rest of my training i go to my car
and i see
this like really pale and faint guy just
in the driver's seat and i'm like yo
is everything okay and he goes oh yeah
it's just i have like a one of my
vertebrae vertebrae's like out of the
out of the spot and like pushes against
my my like i guess part of one of his
nerves so it kind of shuts down like
half of his body just looks super pale
and he's okay yeah i was like oh [ __ ]
i'm like um i'm gonna take you somewhere
you don't look really good because he's
also just sweating a little bit
and he he was like no i think i'm good
and then later he's like you know what
i'm not let me take you up on the offer
do you think you just take me to like a
pt or a chiropractor i think i just
gotta put the disc back in place
so i'm alright cool like jump in the car
he's a big dude too he's like six four
like 270 on the dude this will collapse
it's gonna be you can't carry him yeah
so i put him i put him in the driver's
seat and then uh we're driving
and i found one that was actually open
and it was all the way out in like
torrance area
halfway there this fool was like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm like dude are you okay
and he goes oh my god he's like he's
taken to the hospital take him to the
hospital i'm like do you still want to
go to the pt or not he goes no no take
him to the hospital hospital he goes i
know what it is just tell him to tell
the doctor and he just starts mumbling
the same [ __ ] over and over and i'm like
what the [ __ ] will you find a kaiser was
he lied to you and it was because of
something else it was so we got there
and then we got to the [ __ ] kaiser
and then i'm like the nurse is like all
right we have to take his vitals and do
all that but we're still in the waiting
room for like a whole hour and i'm like
all right you guys are [ __ ] dumb you
guys don't know [ __ ] this guy trains nba
basketball players he already diagnosed
it we just need to put his [ __ ] back in
place because that's what he's been
telling me the whole time and then the
nurse and the other doctor that came out
like no we have to do our entire
protocol i know you guys don't know [ __ ]
this guy knows more than you guys
that's the problem right now right what
was that guy or it's like i checked
webmd i know what it is yeah i was like
i did this thing he's alive this wasn't
so i couldn't even uh we couldn't even
walk into the hospital i have to sprint
across the parking lot to get a
wheelchair because by this time he's
kind of like half out of it already so
i'm sprinting across the [ __ ] parking
lot in a wheelchair so in the waiting
room this was like about to fall out so
i'm like holding him while i'm talking
to the nurse i'm like trust me he
already told me what it is he knows what
what what's going on and they run the
entire protocol they they x-ray them and
what it actually was is he has a heart
leak
and then the blood was coming out of his
heart into his lungs so as the blood was
draining his like left lung uh was take
was getting smaller and smaller and
smaller he can't breathe so he couldn't
breathe and he had a fever and all that
[ __ ]
and then
so when the final doctor it's not a
shoulder nerve yeah it was like uh it
wasn't a slipped vertebrae or anything
like that he has this thing and i was
like oh [ __ ] my bad
is he alive yelling at [ __ ]
like you guys don't know [ __ ] all right
this guy trains nfl dudes nba dudes you
guys are [ __ ] dumb he already fixed
it and thank god they they they drained
it that's why they have the product you
have the protocol and i respect that
like
so much and i respect that guy so much
but i drove myself
i think it's pretty common
yeah it was crazy just bart in a [ __ ]
waiting room yelling at a [ __ ] ton of
trained professionals i want this guy to
take me to the hospital bro i was like
y'all don't know [ __ ]
and then there's a [ __ ] nurse that
came he needs tylenol [ __ ]
p.m this [ __ ] nurse came and i'm like
oh you're ain't gonna cut it i'm like
you see how big this [ __ ] is i
was like give me like two other nurses
because someone came with that was gonna
like help wheel them and now i mean this
will fall out of the wheelchair i'm like
your ass isn't gonna pick him up so i
was mad too and i was trying to
and then afterwards i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry
i'm so sorry this has been a tutorial on
how bart can make things worse but it
was crazy like all his family had to
have to fly in
because it was it was that where he
could have died wow his whole family
flew in from out of state
straw get out of place yeah and it just
started leaking and bloated and how did
they fix it
so they have to drain it they got a boba
straw stuck
[Laughter]
let the uh like lung reseal itself or
some [ __ ]
today's video is brought to you by
fields cbd isn't about what you feel but
it's about what you do not feel
sometimes that's stress sometimes that
pain sometimes that anxiety
okay have you felt anxiety recently yes
well actually pain pain
um mexican food
no
but i was dealing with some kind of
thing called a
temporal mandibular disorder have you
heard of that no so i
after dinner
my jaw started hurting like a [ __ ]
lord and what it ended up happening was
i had like a lockjaw situation where i
couldn't chew what yeah i thought i
could sleep it off and the next morning
i woke up and i was like what the [ __ ]
and i'm not saying that cbd cures me or
anything like that because i don't think
there's anything i could have done but
just rested yeah but it was painful as
[ __ ] right so luckily i had some cbd and
i just went drip drip drip
and then i got a massage right here by
my jaw yeah and i just rested
and um it made it feel like a much more
pleasant
i guess
it would have been worse i think yeah if
i didn't have the cbd around and it
didn't like help me relax and all that
stuff because
one thing i found out about that is it's
stress induced so
um or like a nerve gets pinched or
whatever but a lot of it is like due to
stress so
i don't know to help reduce the stress
and now you feel a little more relaxed
yeah that's tight yep so feels is pretty
easy to take you just take a few couple
of drops and put it under your tongue
and you can feel relaxed and also if
you're new to it they actually have a
hotline that you can call and you can
they'll walk you through it talk to you
about how much dose you should be taking
because that's part of it where you want
to experiment a little bit some people
have super high tolerance so they need a
lot and you can experiment and see what
is the perfect dose for you for you to
feel good so also you could join the
fields monthly membership and it makes
self-care super easy you can save money
on every single order and the coolest
thing is you can cancel any time yeah so
become a member today by going to
feels.com off the record to get 50 off
your first order plus free shipping
that's f e a l s dot com slash off the
record to get 50 off plus free shipping
i was with them and then i was like when
he was a little bit not passing out so
much i'm like yo i'm hella hungry i
gotta post me something
i was like like i took all this energy
yelling at the staff i'm like you want a
burrito and he's like i don't know i'm
good all right cool you ordered
postmates at the wedding room i don't
know once he got in oh okay and it
seemed like he was stabilized wouldn't
she go to the hospital
buffet yeah dude
he doesn't know how to do anything
unless his postman i wanted to stay with
him i don't know what the [ __ ] happened
i would see bart at the vending machine
just buying
also hungry dude
he wasted a lot of energy yelling at the
staff
well you guys just got done working out
and then you did that
yeah
holy [ __ ] i mean shout out to that guy
because he still did the whole workout
video like with this hard [ __ ] heart
how does that even happen no dude how's
your heart start leaking it's [ __ ]
crazy that's wild so has this happened
before because he knew what it was but
but he didn't know it didn't know what
it was oh
yeah because he thought it was a slip
disc that's causing all this like nerve
damage dude that guy is falling apart
yeah and is he healthy he's healthy now
it was just i don't even know what your
heart just randomly leaks on you that's
that's a freak accident a little valve
just
yeah
it was just
crazy dude that's just not i mean human
body is really really interesting
we're so friendly sack of like flesh and
[ __ ] i think about that while i'm
driving sometimes i don't know why when
i'm driving because i think like if i
were to to hit something
the chances of me dying at a very high
speed are very high or like water
yeah
or you're handling a stack of papers and
you just get cut you're like yeah is
that what i'm made of you just get cut
by paper what the [ __ ] that's we're so
fragile paper's sick though paper sticks
paper's tight yeah when you pet a dog
you're like i don't got this protection
fur
yeah when you talk when you touch it
they got thick skin too yeah yeah like
cows that got hide and [ __ ] you punch
them and they don't even feel it
you tip them over they don't even know
what happened
but i mean
you could punch god gave us like
brains and stuff that were we're smarter
yeah
i got a smooth brain i don't know
i don't have this thick skin with this
cowhide
damn dude we like dominated the food
chains
yeah
this guy just punches cows bro
if you were to take a um
an animalistic trait and then uh absorb
it into your own superpowers what would
it be snake dick
independent movement with the penis
that you can't control it no more
control oh you know like a snake has way
more control over they did
no i mean like the snake like if my dick
was a snake like a regular body you want
a vertebrae in your dick a snake dude he
wants a rattle on his balls and he wants
a tongue coming out of the urethra
so his penis penetrates and then his
penis tongue penetrates again we just
hear the shaking i'm like oh joe's
[ __ ]
[ __ ] again dude
that's why you would be a very mean
genie a very mean genie because joe's
like i want a snake dick and then you
put an actual snake on his dick with a
rattle and everything he's like god damn
it i just want to have control over it
tell me you're telling me your wish
see okay but this is okay but okay but
i'm gonna be very careful about this
okay fine okay remember i can't bring
anybody i'm on goat legs i can't make
somebody fall in love with you oh yeah
you can't wish for more wishes
i want
as much money as exists to be controlled
by me but that's not an animal about
animal powers assimilating well no you
said anything i wanted to know and the
rules of the game is if you could have
an animal trade i was gonna redistribute
the wealth because i wanna be satoshi
nakamoto yeah
no because satoshi doesn't have control
over his wall or anything okay okay okay
okay you're an animal dude you got to be
what animal superpower oh dude i want to
be able to jump like a [ __ ] uh
cricket that's good oh
cricket jump why because if as a as a
human being with my legs if i could jump
with the kind of power that they have
for sure i could [ __ ] jump but i hope
god you're not annoying at night then in
my powers i grant you cricket legs and
then your your legs turn into quicker
legs that's why you're a mean genie well
you said you wanted quick legs crooked
legs now if i put my legs together they
chirp and i'm like damn it no one wants
to do sleepovers with steve no but it's
[ __ ] steve you're loud dude a little
bit like yeah you're like kind of exotic
dude and i snore
so i'd have cricket sounds and i snore
that's horrible that's horrible
that it has to be simultaneous
no it doesn't work
i hope you i truly hope you never become
a genie i really do what if
what if i just wanted like
echo location like a bat or a lame
that's lame well it's because this genie
is wack that's lame don't wag me this is
a backfiring genie that's a that's a
dumbass power
hey guess what just happened now this
[ __ ] jean is gonna make you blind
that's [ __ ] up dude see that's what
i'm saying that's what he would do
location
that's like a quiet place he's a good
night vision though you might be blind
in the day but you'll have night vision
nah i don't even want it if i lose a
limb i want to be able to grow back
location you are now
a submarine oh
a submarine
dude
i'm working on my genius would you
rather have water echo location or like
bat air echo location i don't even know
i was even thinking that far obviously
yeah here this guy's not in the water
like a fly all right what am i gonna do
pool tricks
check out this back flip underwater
[ __ ] i want to find the diving stick
quickly
you could be like a dolphin who can tell
if someone's pregnant or not
so
i can do that with the stick i could do
with my eyes i can tell somebody's
pregnant or not
they get to know before they're
they're visible oh i see
i want to be a cow
wow
straight up cow the power of the couch
two stomachs they have a separate
stomach i want to be able to do that
what's the function of the two things
you can eat more
do you know what happens to the cat it's
just a separate bank
i guess so yeah
isn't it because they vomit yes yeah the
first and then they just eat it again
but that's why we get so much nice
vitamins and when we eat beef yeah
oh really yeah
beef is good man they ruminate i think
that's the term or some [ __ ] i don't
know don't make up [ __ ]
dude i want i want my power to be
rumination that's what i want you want
to you want to throw up in yourself no i
don't want that i want to be able to
grow back limbs if i lose it how about
that you want to be a little bit
backfired of that yeah
you are now an iguana [ __ ] dude i'm just
straight up here let's change this into
an animal genie's a hat
do iguanas even do that i don't think so
they do with the tails right no that's
lizards no you don't even have his face
you're a starfish oh i'm a surface right
patrick you're patrick i could dry up
really nice that's about it what else
does starfish how many people use you as
medicine can start fishes even move dude
yeah
they can actually like yeah they're just
like they move slower [ __ ]
oh
a
[ __ ]
you're selling a starfish for me now
does the sea sponge move
yeah it does some some like what the
[ __ ]
current blows the current blows
the current blow baby blows all the
words
[Laughter]
we don't know anything about animals huh
what about okay so we got okay what was
yours again you got snake dick snake
dick rattle dick you got grasshopper
legs off your legs you're a submarine
here's the submarine what the [ __ ]
your son really does pool tricks
he does pool tricks
he called his breath underwater you're a
[ __ ] starfish yeah i'm a starfish you
you she's a cow you are an idiot animal
[ __ ] and i throw it up and eat again
what about you that's unlimited food bro
[ __ ] i might uh
this guy didn't think it through no he's
over here grant all these wishes
he's a stupid genius
what an idiot can't believe it i can't
wish for my own freedom you have to wish
for it for me haven't you seen the
ladder and then you get to be though
come on dude i don't have any kids i
haven't seen live in [ __ ] like
25 years [ __ ] chirping at night
do you want to fly you like flying i do
like flying i do like flying i might
like be something like a ladybug so i
still got my limbs you can't take them
away from me but i got wings on my back
pop out when i want to
because if i said bird flight then y'all
wouldn't [ __ ] just turn me into a tar
and feathered [ __ ]
with a beak he's got wings he's got no
arms and shoulders i'll turn you into a
penguin
i said flight
maybe flying along you like flight
you're a penguin you call me a whack
genie you're worried about
you give me cricket legs dude although i
would [ __ ] dunk on everybody in the
nba dude i would confuse people yeah
jump out of the stadium probably
i would full court dunk you'd have to
train to jump that low that's true
because with your height bro you
probably did yeah that's like stunting
your growth i know you'd have to do
something way bigger well i need to dunk
though because i suck at free throws
trust me
duncan's the only way i trust you
i definitely your best friend would be
pinocchio
oh
he's a good friend to have him like
pinocchio i was like jiminy quickly
re-watched the classics
you haven't watched pinocchio no
that's my favorite one
pinocchio's [ __ ] dark the the
elephant scene's [ __ ] up that's the
pink elephant scene that's dumbo that's
dumbo
that's not pinocchio no are you sure
yeah pinocchio's the one with the
donkeys on the kid island thing where
all the bad guys turn back
it's a donkey yeah
now i don't think you've seen pinocchio
i don't know i don't even watch that's
when his nose grows and then girls use
it as a sex toy oh yeah i see that in a
whale you get stuck in a whale yeah
yeah
it's pretty dark and then it turns into
a real boy and it's a kid's movie it's a
kid's movie but it's kind of crazy it's
my favorite disney movie the great mouse
detective is my favorite disney movie
it's very underrated bro you look like a
great mouse detective what's that you
look like a great mouse detective i
don't know what that means
are you calling him a rat no the rat
king is the bad guy
yeah yeah and he's got cricket legs so
he can't be a rat ah it's a classic but
he's a submarine an elephant fly
[Music]
you